[Music]
[Music]
we just left to set up the laptop and
the projector was on - then I was
sitting there and I noticed that I'd not
plugged in any power so my batteries
would probably run out halfway through
the presentation so when I came up here
to find a way to plug it in I invert lis
unplugged that and so that this would
make a great start to a an interesting
environment between us here that I'm
going to have to reboot and part Oh Oh
God thank you very much well that's a
story of my life okay we'll be in there
in a minute
one of the one of the things that caught
my ear our comp Ferguson talking about
is as the basic shift in paradigms that
occurred in the launching of la I about
the way in which organizations work and
what you do your productivity etcetera
and this is something that you know by
the early 60s I had realized there's a
very big plus that the paradigms that
prevail with which sort of guide the way
people look at the world just have a
surprising impact and they've always
been there and there's a slow basic
change in paradigms as sort of part of
the evolution of a culture etc and it's
very likely that it had a survival value
and having that be relatively slow so a
segment of society didn't shift all of
its beliefs and orientations too rapidly
and fall apart so perhaps that's the
case but it does take a long time for
paradigms to shift well one of the
things I really
coming to in this situation here is
looking at the scale of change that the
technology is catapulting us into and
that all of our paradigms are sort of
very slowly emerging from the old days
in which things changed relatively
slowly so how we in social bodies
organizations institutions how we cope
with the future you know the real
perspective of explosive changes in
technologies is is sort of out of date
and that's a very basic thing and I
learned it in spades by being fired and
things like that and applying for the
universities and corporations to come
and get started in these things in times
in which they were just clearly said
well no one very prominent computer
oriented industry actually turned me
down in 1957 when I said I'm assuming
you're going to go into the digital work
with computers etc no Doug sorry not a
chance
and so these really really brought home
to me this question of it and so if
there were any any kind of thing that
could get across here from my
perspective it would be how do you get
your perspectives and your paradigms to
start readapting really reassess the way
they are so one of them here is is in in
time you know the external environment
which in this case a lot of it is burned
by the digital technology and nano
technologies that are emerging etc in
which over and over and over again we
sort of feel that's come here and yes
there are a few adaptations and such so
our job is to take what the vendors
offer and learn how to adapt it it's
sort of like that but the changes that
are available and the potentials are
just way over that and their impact on
organizations is a really central
central issue and change and
the organization's evolution and
adopting to that stuff is going in these
kind of jerky steps including one la I
instead of like that so it's sort of how
do we how do we shift and cope with that
really really significant change in
there and so this is just one of the
very basic things and would it come real
problems so it's just it's just
inevitable that when all that collides
throughout the world and all sorts of
aspects of its business of its economies
etc and the defenses and all that that
that they're become really strange
situations and very big very big
so that that's one thing they said well
how are we going to cope with those well
we cope with those by collective action
and thinking about it adapting our ways
of doing it such and finding ways to
solve problems like that so there are
opportunities with all of this - and one
of the big big opportunities that just I
seized upon you won't believe it but was
1951 saying computers and we could
interact with them on displays and
shifting the way you can couple your
head in brand new ways to knowledge the
way you can collaborate with others in
there it's just a huge potential there
for boosting our capability for
effective collective action in there
like that
well another thing that with as a few
years went beyond that like that it's
also say we can plug that kind of new
capability back into the improvement
infrastructure and improve the way we
improve which with the challenge of how
rapidly things are changing in the
complex need for that kind of
improvement looked like a sure winner
and it I just used the term
bootstrapping
so that's that was driving me into those
early years and then I ran into this
paradigm in the mid 70s that on one hand
the artificial intelligence people were
saying oh look the computers running
it's so smart that the humans sitting in
front of them won't
have to learn anything the computer will
adapt to that and on the other hand the
people were talking about office
automation what we're going to do is
automate the way we do work now and the
real user is the secretary and those two
things just pushed me right off the
research map and but fortunately we had
enough enough doing we were already
supporting mostly DoD units over the
ARPANET and learning how to use this so
we had a a small business and we got
that to be sold and I went to the
commercial world with that which was a
real really good lesson you know it just
clamped the research down because the
people who know how to run a business
that says you know you you don't get
involved with the customer
they'll just want things instead of mine
so so then another very fortunate thing
is that McDonnell Douglas with perhaps a
foolish sort of thought or something
like that had been successful in
commercially getting access to its CAD
systems so wanted to go into the
information services business in a
bigger way and it started acquiring
companies including the one that had
bought me from the research outfit and
so bingo I was part of McDonnell Douglas
which gave me a new freedom to start
going inside their design development
manufacturing people without seeming
like a vendor I was a cousin and that
was a real talk so it just became very
clear to me then that there was just an
immense value that what we were offering
in the way of collaborative work as
hypermedia that we could do quite a few
more things than than you yet can do
with the web stuff because it's really
really based upon where you can go so
anyway so these are the things I'd like
to talk about and sort of in this this
sort of order and this was an experiment
to give you an order that wasn't just
exactly in linear so the first thing to
talk about is what we talked called a
coevolution frontier and like saying
well where does organizational
capability come
from well it's just based upon your
basic genetic capabilities you know
you've got sensory perceptual mental
cognitive motor capabilities and these
are the things you exercise well yes but
if you take a somebody that's never
grown up in any culture at all they're
totally helpless they're bought like
this so you says well what do you look
at the kind of things that do help
produce more capability for people well
you got a whole long list of that
including all the technologies you can
think of and so I was making a list of
that back in the early 60s just to get
organized about how you really can
amplify human capabilities and whoa my
gosh but always I began to realize oh
look there are a few other things too
that are there and the so there was no
name for that so I've been calling it
the human system and then it becomes
pretty clear that there's a huge amount
of what we call augmentation over here
as well as that in the tool system so
the the thing then if one talks about an
explosive technologies on this right
side and one looks at how things such as
the plow or the weaving looms or the
printing press came in on the right hand
side and the ensuing evolution on the
left hand side in order to harness that
created big changes in there so that if
the scaling thing is becoming really
important and I'd actually done a study
of scaling stuff in the late 50s
knowing that digital technologies were
going to have to smaller and smaller and
faster and cheaper and that was going to
come by learning how to build a much
smart
so I didn't got a chance to a few months
to study about scaling and and because
once I had worked at Ames aeronautical
lab my first job out of school like that
and had known aeronautics people and
talking about Reynolds numbers and
back out and that the only you had to
get the same Reynolds number and all the
pressure etc etc so that the scale model
would give you know relativity valuable
data and so I learned a lot more about
all of that and one of the real things
that came out of it was if if you're
used to building and working with
devices at a given scale and suddenly
the change of scale in some of the
important parameters as it changes
slowly some of the quantitative
characteristics will change but past a
certain point it gets qualitative and
things won't work anymore and so I would
try to give lectures that year and I
would just tell people well suppose
everything in this room and cleaning all
the people just suddenly scaled up in
size by a factor of 10 and there's three
dimensions would you notice it see and
so everybody says well let's see there'd
be the same angle subtended by anybody's
they'd be ten times as far away but ten
times as big etcetera
I probably wouldn't notice but then you
start pointing out how much more you
weigh well ten times ten times ten
thousand times as much oh how much
stronger are you oh I don't know well
somebody in there would know that the
strength of your bones and muscles is
really proportional to the cross section
area so you're only hundred times as
strong and your chair is only a hundred
times as strong so that means unless
your chair is designed with a safety
factor of ten you know you're doomed so
you fall on the floor so your bones will
break because they can't stand it and
your lungs are only a hundred times as
large for a thousand times the
metabolism needs and etc etc so you'd be
dead pretty soon but anyway this this
surprising set of things when you you're
not used to thinking about that scaling
so that really came combed in that study
so I looked at this diagram and I said
wow with the scale of change that's
erupting and for coming here with a
nanotechnology and the digital stuff
that the change is over here that are
going to be taking place some force
because as you adopt all this and this
against all the turmoil here but some of
the changes to take advantage of that
they're gonna be a lot of surprises in
that and so that's what I started really
to pursue and especially in this
language and the getting your ex getting
your concepts symbolized externalized
manipulated in brand new ways and
realizing that the way we're used to
things as they're done in print has just
got very little to do about how
effectively you're harnessing your basic
mechanisms in there so y'all go to read
much more flexibly getting the views you
want moving around etc and much leads on
there but pretty soon you're doing
things that look hard to learn and it's
an unnatural to use so the mantra at the
time was easy to learn and natural to
use and that's been inhibiting our
exploration of this just immensely and
even in the Defense Department we going
to DARPA and try to talk about some of
the things and they'll say well you give
this great system that will help people
in a crisis but they have to be able to
learn how to use it in 20 minutes senior
says oh well let's see you've got some
other important missions during times
like that like perhaps interceptor
planes right yeah so with an important
mission like that you expect any jeep
driver to learn how to fly that airplane
in 15 minutes
well no but so anyway the perspective
about how important missions would be in
handling complex knowledge work it just
says hey wait a minute
it's will be very important to go after
high-performance stuff and there's just
a lot in this domain that we could talk
about all day but we not going to and so
any capability your organization has
depends on the coevolution of that thing
which includes stuff in your world but
also even in athletics world are just
general business operations so there's
something then I did was say oh very
crudely because each the tool system has
many dimensions to itself and so does a
human system but if you just do it a
little bit roughly like this you say
I've got a human tool space
and ones organization would fit in there
someplace so what if we go around the
world looking at different societies and
see where they fit some use more or less
technology and more advanced human
system development like that
and we say okay their distributions
right and someplace in there there's the
organization you belong to that you're
probably pretty proud of and you think
it's right out near the frontier see we
can anticipate today these different
changes in the technology and in the
human system stuff and we're a little
bit lagging in the human system but boy
lii is taking this care of us moving us
into here all right well then let's
let's let's just say there's a
distribution like that and then let's
talk about the scaling business a little
bit this as well now wait a minute what
if we really think the technology is
moving at a rate that's faster well our
whole way of changing our organizations
evolved over centuries and thinking
about where these boundaries weren't
that far away but what if this is way
that the paradigm shifted in people's
minds and they realized oh wait a minute
here here we are with our distribution
and here's all that you can anticipate
today and the technology with
commensurate changes in here we suddenly
have a new frontier so we should have
different paradigms about how we move
our organizations into that and then
somebody also come and look at it like
this guy from California and you say
well you know why don't you just be a
little bolder about that damn and you
says hey that we haven't really seen
what nanotechnology will do and it's
just that scaling things down it's just
going to produce capacity and
capabilities and bandwidth and
everything else we never dreamed of and
oh I see and that's something how's that
affecting world well okay what about
computers and things will get so small
that you could surgically implant them
and Hank
get the energy to drive them from your
metabolism and they could connect to
your nerves and they can also have
sensor things that go beyond what your
sensory capabilities can do and all that
connects in and boy you know you can
become they call them cyborgs or
something that really Tomatoes but the
scale of things is going to be able to
do that just is just a couple examples
out of the air and you're like that see
and then intelligent agents are really
just inevitable going to come in they're
beginning to and hey how are you gonna
learn how if you've got a whole crew of
slaves it's not realistic to think of
them just sort of bumping along and help
you with spell checkers and things like
that they're gonna be things that you
can learn how to steer and guide and
will interact with etc and will take the
skill and learning how to do that but
boost your power a lot so he says oh you
know that frontier is more like this the
relative scale and none of our processes
for social or business adaptation they
all were evolved with the frontier being
very near like that so it takes a real
call to reexamine what's the processes
what are the processes by which our
organizations can adapt and start
harnessing this thing and our societies
learn how to cope with it etc so we need
we need to look at different processes
for our evolving and this has led me to
that bootstrapping and then it leads to
things like oh let's reexamine the
infrastructure by which our
organizations improve and see if the
improvement infrastructure can be
improved and then if you can bootstrap
it so that's that's the message and it
turned out that that for the formulation
we evolved that one of the key elements
in that improvement infrastructure is
what we call that an improvement
community something to have special
focus on and la is an improvement
community and then it's saying that look
if we can bring the modernization work
especially in collective knowledge work
into appropriate in improvement
communities this is going to give us an
extra second degree acceleration or
something like that it gives extra
strategic leverage in the improvement
process and so that's one of the reasons
why when I talked to her I thought oh
boy there's a high tech improvement
community and it's based in MIT which
has a few people that are used to
working with information and etc and
it's a great great model so let's talk a
little more about that so one of them
strategic things that somehow there have
to be is waste established outposts out
in that frontier and it isn't a matter
of going out there and setting up a
group of people that by themselves are
just doing startling things the way that
that's going to show organizations how
to go is if those are doing real work
and it'd be very handy if the real work
they're doing is a visible part of the
work the organization's are doing
already so that means you don't set them
up in a laboratory and glass bowl doing
their special things so there are a lot
of thinking about that and how do you
get the high performance groups that are
going to be doing that how they compose
what are they going to do so all of that
that's an important part of thinking
this way so we've talked about this
picture the coevolution frontier and
let's talk about then one of the very
important improvement categories this
strategic in there as a collective
intelligence
so you said you have a bunch of people
and they're involved in some
organization and this bond dollar kind
of thing in here with all the cross
connections implying that every every
member of this organization needs to
have a channel for communicating with
every
one and so that's the way they work
together then it's obvious that if
they're going to get collectively
smarter they have to manage the
knowledge in there and in the
traditional sense between a document as
a it's a container with some authored
knowledge in it like that you said well
it's going to be documents and with the
way the web has taught people like that
it's easy now to tell them that the web
is a beautiful way to start managing
their knowledge and how do you go about
them making them smart well that's
that's something we could talk hours and
hours about too but the experience and
the motivations and the things we
experimented with just really show a lot
and and so it's how do you really move
beyond the knowledge work capabilities
that the vendors can offer you because
the user organisations aren't yet
proactively up ahead enough to say I
want to start learning about their
really far-out things rather than the
way it is now that what we're going to
think about is what we can implement
today or tomorrow and we have two
political problems of conflict inside
our organization of people that don't
want to have to change that much or our
suspicious all kinds of what you end up
realizing are very natural cultural
impedances that so anyway and so there's
there's in the end there going to be a
dynamic knowledge repository that's
electronic hypermedia linked like that
and the ways for organizations to manage
that they they want to be a lot more
alert about the outside world so they're
going to have to be able to go out and
actively ingest and assess and organize
the intelligence about what the outside
world is doing and this this social
organism that you call an organization
is going to be judged in its IQ a lot by
oh how sensitive and perceptual is that
about
what's going on the outside world that
offers opportunities or threats and when
they either those occurs how smart and
clever are their plan for how to cope
and how well do they then marshal their
resources and coordinate them in coping
and how quick are they to readapt and
shift and you begin realizing the way
the future is going to go that the
annual yearly budget thing is probably
going to have to go by the boards and
become a much more dynamic and a lot of
things are changing they record a
dialogue and the knowledge product are
just there a way to say Oh any given
time you really want all the plans the
designs the current state of things the
current state your understanding about
the outside world the current state of
the scenarios that you're depending upon
etcetera is all sort of what's called
knowledge products available for people
to use in there and how they study at
how it's organized is some whole field
of exploration itself and then at any
given time there's a lot of dialogue
about it and you're in the midst of a
dialogue exercise right now it's morning
and recording that well what I say and
what I present here like that the
technology is already available for that
to get nailed down and be on a web and
so on automatically transcribing my
speech is much well enough at least so
that you could scan for that so you can
go back and then find out what I said
and look at it again and say oh yeah
that's interesting and then the way you
can make comments on it or the links
that you'll be able to provide can point
to a particular passage that I spoke and
its associated diagram or run up and
down that or cleverly say hey I want to
hear what he says and then show the
three the three kind of slide pictures
that he showed that went on that and
then I'd like when you follow that link
to highlight something there because
that's what I like to talk about well
that's the kind of link things that were
part of our plan etc and
basic underlying standards for the
extended markup language and such well
will provide things like that so then
people make comments on this and
questions and the dialogue comment on
the comments grows etc so these are all
things that technology can offer today
but it's just a introductory example of
this recorded dialogue is a dynamic part
of integrating intelligence and arguing
about what's there now by which your
knowledge product evolves and changes so
every organization that survives into
very far in the next century it's going
to have to start living like this so
there are a few other things that you
think about in this and say oh you know
if I'm if I'm a division or a part of a
bigger organization my division or
project program is going to have its own
knowledge repository it's got to be
dynamic and it's totally relevant to
what we're doing and yet the whole
organization does too and so every one
of these nodes around here has its own
dynamic repository as well as the whole
thing and so all of those are evolving
concurrently and yet need to stay and
sync that none of them is looking at a
future or something that is in any way
contradict contrary to any of the others
so it's that concurrency thing that
really hits the demand yet you don't
hear that very often you know they have
to have interoperability but that's
scaling so the challenge is large and
the challenge there is something that
you don't just get by getting new a new
product out by a given vendor or
something it's got to be something that
evolves in a very different way and so
we ended up with this acronym Kodiak
saying that that describes a core set of
capabilities in the future smart
organization that they can currently
develop integrate and apply knowledge
it's the best we could sort of do so we
use that term a lot
and say how do you go about improving
that and you can just guess that that
everyone almost every objective you'd
like to set up for what la I can do can
do a lot better if the organizations
were better at this and a very important
thing oh la I could operate a lot more
effectively so where should you put your
initial exploratory energy about doing
outposts that are trying to learn how to
do this Oh
strategically speaking la I it's a place
to start investing in learning advanced
how to do this so I got some great
lessons interacting with the Donald
Douglas people so maybe show them that
well so you have a couple thousand
people working inside of the McConnell
plant from a fighter plane but look at
what you have in these tiers of
suppliers and the kind of interactions
and design coordination etc have to go
on there so there's a real example for
concurrency and interoperability
requirement so these are things that you
very rarely I rarely hear about when
vendors are selling you things etc but
this is the real that's something the
this is the real marketplace so anyway
this open hyper document system is
something that evolved in in our minds
like 14 years ago it with Donald Douglas
about saying you really really have to
come out with a standard open hyper
document system and the HTML offered a
beautiful way to get a standard way for
publishing and the XML is starting to
advance it but most of that is being
done by vendors the evolutional
standards and what is critically needed
really is the proactive involvement of
the end-user organizations and the
evolution of the standards for this
thing so these are sort of the
properties that all these things and
then it becomes pretty clear that
there's a huge amount of what we call
augmentation over here as well as that
in the tool system so the the thing then
if one talks about an explosive
technologies on this right side and one
looks at how things such as the plow or
the weaving looms or the printing press
came in on the right hand side and the
ensuing evolution on the left hand side
in order to harness that created big
changes in there so that if the scaling
thing is becoming really important and
I'd actually done a study of scaling
stuff in the late 50s
knowing that digital technologies were
going to have to get smaller and smaller
and faster and cheaper and that was
going to come by learning how to build a
much smaller so I didn't got a chance to
do a few months of study about scaling
and and because once I had worked at
Ames aeronautical lab my first job out
of school like that and had known
aeronautics people and talking about
reynolds numbers and things like that
and that the only you had to get the
same reynolds number and all the
pressure etc etc so that the scale model
would give you know relatively valuable
data and so I learned a lot more about
all of that and one of the real things
that came out of it was if if you're
used to building and working with
devices at a given scale and suddenly
the change of scale and some of the
important parameters as it changes
slowly some of the quantitative
characteristics will change but past a
certain point it gets qualitative and
things won't work anymore and so I would
try to give lectures in here and I would
just tell people well suppose everything
in this room and including all the
people just suddenly scaled up in size
by a factor of 10 and there's three
dimensions would you notice it see and
so everybody says well let's see there'd
be the same angle subtended by anybody
they'd be ten times as far away but ten
times as big etcetera yeah I probably
wouldn't notice but then you start
pointing out how much more you weigh
well ten times ten times ten thousand
times as much oh how much stronger are
you I don't know well somebody in there
would know that the strength of your
bones and muscles is really proportional
to the cross section area
hundred times as strong and you chairs
only a hundred times as strong so that
means unless your chair is designed with
a safety factor of 10 you're doomed so
you fall on the floor so your bones will
break because they can't stand it and
your lungs are only a hundred times as
large for a thousand times the
metabolism needs and etc etc so you'll
be dead pretty soon but anyway this this
surprising set of things when you you're
not used to thinking about that scaling
so that really came home to that study
so I looked at this diagram and I said
Wow
with a scale of change that's erupting
and for coming here with the
nanotechnology and the digital stuff
that the change is over here that are
going to be taking place some forced
because as you adopt all this and this
and gets all the turmoil here but some
of the changes to take advantage of that
there gonna be a lot of surprises in
that and so that's what I started really
to pursue and especially in this
language and the getting your ex getting
your concepts symbolized externalized
manipulated and brand new ways and
realizing that the way we're used to
things as they're done in print it's
just got very little to do about how
effectively your harnessing your basic
mechanisms in there so y'all be able to
read much more flexibly getting the
views you want moving around etc and
much leads on there but pretty soon
you're doing things that look hard to
learn and it's an unnatural to use so
the mantra at the time was easy to learn
and natural to use and that's been
inhibiting our exploration of this just
immensely and even in a Defense
Department we go in to DARPA and try to
talk about some of the things and
they'll say well you gives us a great
system that will help people in a crisis
but they have to be able to learn how to
use it in 20 minutes senior says oh well
let's see you've got some other
important missions during times like
that like perhaps interceptor planes
right yeah so with an important mission
like that you expect any jeep driver to
learn how to fly that airplane in 15
minutes
well no but so anyway the
perspective about how important missions
would be in handling complex knowledge
work it just says hey wait a minute it's
will be very important to go after
high-performance stuff and there's just
a lot in this domain that we could talk
about all day but we not going to and so
any capability your organization has
depends on the coevolution of that thing
which includes stuff in your world but
also even in athletics world are just
general business operations so there's
something then I did was say oh very
crudely because each the tool system has
many dimensions to itself and so does a
human system but if you just do it a
little bit roughly like this you say
I've got a human tool space and one's
organization would fit in there
someplace so what if we go around the
world looking at different societies and
see where they fit some use more or less
technology and more advanced human
system development like that and we say
ok their distributions right and
someplace in there there's the
organization you belong to that you're
probably pretty proud of and you think
it's right out near the frontier see we
can anticipate today these different
changes in the technology and in the
human system stuff and we're a little
bit lagging in the human system but boy
lii is taking this care of us moving us
into here all right well then let's
let's let's just say there's a
distribution like that and then let's
talk about the scaling business a little
bit it says well now wait a minute what
if we really think the technology is
moving at a rate that's faster well our
whole way of changing our organizations
evolved over centuries and thinking
about where these boundaries weren't
that far away but what if this is why
that the paradigm shifted in people's
minds and they realized oh wait a minute
here here we are with our distribution
and here's all that you can anticipate
today and the technology with
commensurate changes in here we suddenly
have
a new frontier so we should have
different paradigms about how we move
our organizations into that and then
somebody else will come and look at it
like this guy from California and he'll
say well you know why don't you just be
a little bolder about that damn and you
says hey that we haven't really seen
what nanotechnology will do and it's
just that scaling things down it's just
going to produce capacity and
capabilities and bandwidth and
everything else we never dreamed of and
oh I see and that's something how's that
affecting we're well okay what about
computers and things will get so small
that you could surgically implant them
and I can get the energy to drive them
from your metabolism and they could
connect to your nerves and they can also
have sensor things that go beyond what
your sensory capabilities can do and all
that connects in and boy you know you
can become they call them cyborgs or
something that really Tomatoes but the
scale of things is going to be able to
do that just is just a couple examples
out of the air you're like that see and
then intelligent agents are really just
inevitable come in they're beginning to
and hey how are you gonna learn how if
you've got a whole crew of slaves it's
not realistic to think of them just sort
of bumping along and helping you spell
checkers and things like that they're
gonna be things that you can learn how
to steer and guide and will interact
with etc and will will take the skill
and learning how to do that but boost
your power a lot so you said oh you know
that frontiers more like this the
relative scale and none of our processes
for social or business adaptation they
all were evolved with the frontier being
very near like that so it takes a real
call to reexamine what's the processes
what are the processes by which our
organizations can adapt and start
harnessing this thing
and our societies learn how to cope with
it etc so we need we need to look at
different processes for our evolving and
this has led me to that bootstrapping
and then it leads to things like oh
let's reexamine the infrastructure by
which our organizations improve and see
if the improvement infrastructure can be
improved and then if you can bootstrap
it so that's that's the message and it
turned out that for the formulation we
evolved that one of the key elements in
that improvement infrastructure is what
we called an improvement community
something to have special focus on and
la I is an improvement community and
then it's saying that look if if we can
bring the modernization work especially
and collective knowledge work into
appropriate in improvement communities
this is going to give us an extra second
degree acceleration or something like
that it gives extra strategic leverage
in the improvement process and so that's
one of the reasons why when I talk to
her all I thought oh boy here's a
high-tech improvement community and it's
based in MIT which has a few people that
are used to working with information and
etc and it's a great great model so
let's talk a little more about that so
one of them strategic things that
somehow there have to be is waste
established outposts out in that
frontier and it isn't a matter of going
out there and setting up a group of
people that by themselves are just doing
startling things the way that that's
going to show organizations how to go is
if those are doing real work and it'd be
very handy if the real work they're
doing is a visible part of the work the
organization's are doing already so that
means you don't set them up in a
laboratory a glass bowl doing their
special things so there are a lot of
thinking about that
and how do you get the high-performance
groups that are going to be doing that
how they composed what are they going to
do so all of that that's an important
part of thinking this way so we've
talked about this picture of the
coevolution frontier and let's talk
about then one of the very important
improvement categories the strategic in
there as a collective intelligence so
you say you have a bunch of people and
they're involved some organization and
this bond dollar kind of thing in here
with all of the cross connections
implying that every every member of this
organization needs to have a channel for
communicating with every other one and
so that's the way they work together
then it's obvious that if they're going
to get collectively smarter they have to
manage the knowledge in there and in the
traditional sense between a document is
a it's a container with some authored
knowledge in it like that you said well
it's going to be documents and with the
way the web has taught people like that
it's easy now to tell them that the web
is a beautiful way to start managing
their knowledge and how do you go about
then making them smart well that's
that's something we could talk hours and
hours about too but the experience and
the motivations and the things we
experimented with just really show a lot
and and so it's how do you really move
beyond the knowledge work capabilities
that the vendors can offer you because
the user organizations aren't yet
proactively up ahead enough to say I
want to start learning about their
really far-out things rather than the
way it is now that what we're going to
think about is what we can implement
today or tomorrow and we have two
political problems of of conflict inside
our organization of people that don't
want to have to change that much or our
suspicious all kinds of what you end up
realizing are very natural cultural
impedances that so anyway and so there's
there's in the end they're going to be a
dynamic knowledge repository that's
electronic hypermedia linked like that
and the ways for organizations to manage
that they they want to be a lot more
alert about the outside world so they're
going to have to be able to go out and
actively ingest and assess and organize
the intelligence about what the outside
world is doing and this this social
organism that you call an organization
is going to be judged in its IQ
a lot by oh how sensitive and perceptual
is that about the what's going on the
outside world that offers opportunities
or threats and when they either those
occurs how smart and clever are their
plan for how to cope and how well do
they then marshal their resources and
coordinate them in coping and how quick
are they to readapt and shift and you
begin realizing the way the future is
going to go that the annual yearly
budget thing is probably going to have
to go by the boards and become a much
more dynamic and a lot of things are
changing they record a dialogue and the
knowledge product are just there a way
to say Oh
any given time you really want all the
plans the designs the current state of
things a current state your
understanding about the outside world
the current state of the scenarios that
you're depending upon etcetera is all
sort of which called knowledge products
available for people to use in there and
how they study at how it's organized is
some whole field of exploration itself
and then at any given time there's a lot
of dialogue about it and you're in the
midst of a dialogue exercise right now
this morning and recording that well
what I say and what I present here like
that the technology is already available
for that to get nailed down and be on a
web and
so on automatically transcribing my
speech is much well enough at least so
that you could scan for that so you can
go back and then find out what I said
and look at it again and say oh yeah
that's interesting and then the way you
can make comments on it or the links
that you'll be able to provide can point
to a particular passage that I spoke and
its associated diagram or run up and
down that or cleverly say hey I want to
hear what he says and then show the
three the three kind of slide pictures
that he showed that went on that and
then I'd like when you follow that link
to highlight something there because
that's what I like to talk about well
that's the kind of link things that were
part of our plan etc and the basic
underlying standards for the extended
markup language and such well we'll
provide things like that so then people
make comments on this and questions and
the dialogue comment on the comments
grows etc so these are all things that
technology can offer today but it's just
a introductory example of this recorded
dialogue is a dynamic part of
integrating intelligence and arguing
about what's there now by which your
knowledge product evolves and changes so
every organization that survives into
very far in the next century it's going
to have to start living like this
so there are a few other things that you
think about in this is say oh you know
if I'm if I'm a division or a part of a
bigger organization my division or
project or program is going to have its
own knowledge repository that's got to
be dynamic and it's totally relevant to
what we're doing and yet the whole
organization does too and so every one
of these nodes around here has its own
dynamic repository as well as the whole
thing and so all of those are evolving
concurrently and yet need to stay in
sync that none of them is looking at a
future or something that is in any way
contradict contrary to any of the others
so it's that concurrency thing that
really hits the demand yet you don't
hear that very often you know they have
to have interoperability but that's
scaling so the challenge is large and
the challenge there is something that
you don't just get by getting new a new
product out by a given vendor or
something it's got to be something that
evolves in a very different way and so
we ended up with this acronym Kodiak
saying that that describes a core set of
capabilities in the future
smart organization that they can
currently develop integrate and apply
knowledge it's the best we could sort of
do so we use that term a lot and say how
do you go about improving that and you
can just guess that that everyone almost
every objective you'd like to set up for
what la I can do can do a lot better if
the organization's were better at this
and a very important thing oh la I could
operate a lot more effectively so where
should you put your initial exploratory
energy about doing outposts that are
trying to learn how to do this
Oh strategically speaking la I it's a
place to start investing in learning
advances how to do this so I got some
great lessons interacting with Donald
Douglas people so maybe show them that
well so you have a couple thousand
people working inside of the McDonald
plant from a fighter plane but look at
what you have in these tiers of
suppliers and the kind of interactions
and design coordination etc have to go
on there so there's a real example for
concurrency and interoperability
requirement so these are things that you
very rarely very rarely hear about when
vendors are selling you things etc but
this is the real that's gonna be the
this is the real marketplace so anyway
this open hyper document system is
something that evolved in in our minds
like 14 years ago Donald Uggla's about
saying you really really have to come
out with a standard open hyper document
system and the HTML offered a beautiful
way to get a standard way for publishing
and the XML is starting to advance it
but and most of that is being done by
vendors the evolution of standards and
what is critically needed really is the
proactive involvement of the end-user
organizations in the evolution of the
standards for this thing so these are
sort of the properties that all these
things
my watch ran out of battery so you can
you can just tell how well I'm connected
to today's world so I had to borrow URLs
so this means he can't tell me when I
might die this time and I was a very
clever tactical thing don't you think
anyway
I should have borrowed everybody's
watched there so he would have no way
anyway here again that's the sort of
strategic need to get the end user
organisation or the real customer is the
organisation in in the IT world that's
coming up and that's here now so so how
do your organization's move into this
space and it's only going to happen if
they're if it becomes a real standard
for the knowledge packages that it's not
a standard set by a vendor that this is
my kind of file or something so there's
a standard file and not only that
there's standard sets of functional
capabilities that can be applied to
those things and with a standard file
there
they're a whole array of this yet
unexplored under you unutilized
properties that can be embedded inside
the document and some that we built in
ours for instance were that that the it
was just early early experiments with it
that the identity and the date time
second stamp on every paragraph or line
of code was the last edited time and
this was really interesting the way you
could employ that property it's like oh
there's there's some problems and our
source code has all been was hyperlinked
from from the late sixties on so five
hundred thousand lines of it did you
just jump to any place and our email was
hyperlinked from 1970 on so it could
point to any place in the code or
anything else and you could also point
to any passage in an email and
just living that way and so so they're
new bugs in the software oh well it's
probably in this this section of
software well one of the things we said
it's every time you jump on something
you you're linked and specify what view
and you can say just show me the first
line of every paragraph or if it's
hierarchically organized just the first
two levels or something like this or
here's a content filter to put on and
only show me those paragraphs or lines
that have a certain content or or were
changed in within a given period so
there's some some new bug isn't there
like that will just show me something
was changed in the last month and you
see five or you know three or four
people that have been changing and then
while it always tickles me is Oh Fred
he's he's always the problem
just show me everything's fred has
changed it I'll find the bug see and so
we had all these kind of ways to live
and it's learning how to implant the
kind of properties that give you
extended capabilities beyond the space
and a document now is not a model of a
paper document at all with its rigid
thickness only you can scroll you know
you can jump very flexibly have all
kinds of viewing options and things that
you learn to apply so it's inevitable
that that comes but that won't be
interoperable available unless they get
to be a standard way in which the
document is suppressed so there's a
whole set of standards out there that
are the standards working group etc that
are available for evolution but it's
just absolutely imperative that end-user
organizations get proactively involved
and one way to do it is through because
source you like this and we'll show you
more like that so we actually have
funding now to proceed on this when I
say we now it's this this whole picture
about what's needed in proactive and
used organizations emerged so strongly
in the late 80s for me when I was at
McDonnell Douglas and
not the point at them as anybody was
particularly reactive every organization
had the same kind of reactions but we
couldn't we demonstrated what you could
do in things and we're showing how you
can make a link in the requirements or a
project status report and a link
pointing to something in a CAD system
that wouldn't I got to the CAD system
you got the protocols arranged so it
would evoke the right kind of macro that
would produce a given view and scale and
view of a certain thing so they would
highlight it so that that's the way that
the user and he seeing this comment on
it could go look or in in the cabin
environment like that they're talking
about the plating or the finishing or
something like that and they could have
in a common sort of sense a link that go
right to the actual specifications of
those things so all those things were
just there to add to what we could do
and it it it ended up in the four head
of the corporate CIO was really between
a rock and a hard place because he says
well deck and Hill at Packard and IBM
none of them are talking about this of
course the language he used at the time
was a little more colorful than that but
he says I'm not going to go ahead and do
something we're out there they don't
even recognize they don't even know what
a link is so so you know it's just a
question they're like the world was not
ready and you can't go point a finger at
any particular person the world just
wasn't ready for some reason that the
evolution of their thinking in scenarios
about the future about the inevitable
you know much more capacity and
bandwidth per dollar etc that was just
inevitable that changing organization is
going to take a lot longer than the
change in that technology so anyway so
one of my daughter's who'd been working
with this area and also she and her
husband had gotten experience with a
star
we set up this bootstrap Institute ten
years ago to say let's raise our flying
and start telling the world and it's
been a very interesting experience but
the momentum is slowly picking up and
accelerating now and that there's a
bootstrap Alliance that started that
says hey let's get strategically set up
so that people can participate in this
and last november by george japan set up
a japanese chapter that would strap
alliance and because one of the things
we were talking about is hey this is a
scalable thing it's got to be to have a
infrastructure that really will work
like this needs to be scalable and
should be scalable to national or global
so and it'd be benefit be worthwhile to
set up a national improvement
infrastructure well the Japanese aren't
quite exactly saying that's what they're
doing but they're setting up their own
chapter that to be participating in that
and so now we come back home and say
well let's get let's get us the more
proactive and we're getting a few other
leads from other countries but the the
whole idea of really paying more
attention to the improvement
infrastructure and how it can be
improved and the strategies for
investing in it etc so anyway collective
IQ ABCs of improvement is the next one
and so this is condensing and
abstracting quite a bit but go look at
any one of your business organizations
and KL AI and just look at these three
categories of activity so don't say that
categories of people or something at the
outset but the a category is everything
the way the business has done today
every operational activity that
conducting in the business today which
includes hiring new people and training
them to do the work that you're doing
today so then any activity that's
improving the capability to do your a
act
and just categorize that as a be and
very often it's somebody that wears an a
hat many hours a day but on B it goes
into a committee that's talking about
something changing or something or
planning or actually implementing it or
it's a budgeted change project and the
change agents often spend most of time
in there except then there's this other
category that became important as we
were thinking about it it's what what
activity is there to improve the
capability to do the B to do the
changing and so in in a real sense that
all our viewers that are from
organizations here today are have your C
hat on and we found a lot of very
interesting things that start evolving
when you're thinking this way which
again would you know you could dig deep
learn to dialogue and we can be here a
half a day or more on that so this this
this was very important and one of the
big things is when the frontier is
exploding B and C become a lot more
important and C which hardly gets any
recognition at all today in any
corporation or something becomes much
more important so let's talk about that
a little bit that's sort of like say
that all right we've got a frontier out
there that we're going to try to go
after and the C is sort of like the
Scout it's sort of in order to improve
your ability to improve which here would
mean in order to improve your ability to
get out there move your organization you
need to scout it find out what's out
there and what would be the path
different trails that are available and
oh how you can sort of teach the beeth
kinds and you says oh the B is the guy
that's got a he's a wagon train master
or something he's got to move you out
there and so the business that Park
talking people about being change agents
is both of them are change agents B and
C but it becomes important to clarify
when you're in a B role or a C role
and then it'd be very important for
organizations to start trying to do
their auditing and something so that
they can tell you how much money they're
spending what the budgets are for those
two because just like budgets for
product Rd or something where you're
sort of my time you're setting your
budgets you you sort of take stock of
what the rest of your industry does like
that because if you're too far off from
them you know you're either behind the
ball or you might be overspending or
what anyway this this is something we
haven't found any organization that even
has an auditing set up where they can
classify and tell you what that C is and
yet and yet the thing about this
explosive 40 yeah thank you
so anyway these every these steps were
taking through here like that or things
that they're a lot more digging into one
can get and my what I would really
secretly like is to get la I as an
organization interested in this whole
strategy and start knocking on the door
of our alliance to say hey we'd like to
we like to participate because the
Alliance is trying to you know is its
job is to help different improvement
communities do their job better so
anyway so this is sort of objective for
organizations front to your perspective
and just a part of the improvement
infrastructure we're talking about so
the next step we can go to is talking
about improvement communities and here
you can almost use la I group so among
your your manufacturing organizations
that are joining here and even some of
the agencies you can sort of look up and
down the street and check out some of
them that have a similar set of
capabilities that they're interested in
improving and so in this case the lean
mean aerospace activity capability so
you say alright we're doing that in
common so our bees have similar kind of
things to do and sometimes we'd like to
be a little bit proprietary about what
you actually do in ace so some of the
bee things we would just as soon keep on
our belt but but oh wait a minute how
about the sea well suddenly that foot is
going way out there and there's we have
to invest a lot more in sea in order to
be able to know how we're going to move
our organization etc so it really
benefits us to invest collectively and
that's just basically why investing in
participating in LA I it's exploring and
finding out what's out there to do and
change so that you can decide inside how
to change and do it so he says really
so we just said oh so what la I
essentially is is a si community you
know again you hear than a community
sense to do common work on si and so you
say that's that's really very important
so out of the world a lot of consortium
that are doing that and and other kind
improvement communities that don't call
themselves consortium we call themselves
a professional society or a trade
association they're doing that so these
all have a special sort of potential in
boosting rusta society's capabilities so
this this is just the description of it
so one of the things we talk about is
saying oh we talk about what if an
improvement community decides it's going
to really be a proactive evolutionary
pusher towards becoming having this
collective IQ of itself a lot more
effective you know not waiting till all
this member organizations do but saying
oh if we start doing it ourselves more
aggressively proactively really learning
how to do that collective knowledge work
of the consortium then we're doing a lot
better job there and and the whole whole
pursuit of how our members can improve
will be facilitated improved but also
the very experience that they all can
share by having this thing be its
advanced as possible is a real
enlightenment about what they can take
back in side their organizations and
very soon in la i that would become one
of its capabilities it's interested in
transferring into your cases to
essentially how you do this kodiak
concurrently develop integrate apply
knowledge in a better improve manner
what benefit every one of the
organizations it's a member of that so
that can become a direct
sort of pursuit of one of the
capabilities but also the front-runner
and it's not just the knowledge that
that can collect and be in that dynamic
knowledge repository it's the experience
because how things can work in there and
so that becomes very important so we
talked about the improvement vector the
vector of capabilities that an
improvement community is out after
collectively improving and then we talk
about if they are using this kind of
advanced stuff in a really proactive
improving way we've been calling them
Nix networked improvement communities
and so it's it's so that an improvement
community that's not actively doing that
it's just a nick and some of our members
have fun talking about and they're just
a nick you know trying to be derogatory
when you really could become a Nick C so
anyway this is this is the idea that la
is a real candidate and so always tell
me me that plans that have been working
on anyway and you've already gotten a
website but it says oh the extension so
these presentations go online and then
the dialogue about them all and much
more can start being in there and much
more of the practice for how that begins
to be an important part of the way you
participate so it isn't just la i
central staff its la i participants that
get involved and have to expend energy
in participating in that evolution and
the way it works and you says well you
know maybe la is benefits aren't going
to be worth it
so you says well just look at what
you're learning about how advanced
knowledge work can be done and that's a
real pilot operation for what you could
bring back inside your organization and
LA eyes roll can pretty soon be there to
facilitate that too so it can be a
multiple winner and
so anyway this is the sort of a thing so
you consider the payoff the aerospace
industry la I converted itself into a
Nick and not just a web user but an
example of a distributed organization
actively and persistently improving its
Kodiak capability and Kaktovik you so
this is sort of applied challenge people
and it LA I would become more effective
and proving its members critical
capabilities and incidentally early
indirect boosting of the members
collective IQ for the operator looks
like that so here's the idea for the
bootstrap Alliance it's now going into
its second year it's saying look what
are the member organizations it oh the
idea is that they are Nix and that the
common improvement vector that this Nick
is there to do is to improve the
capability of its members to be better
Nix so that's the way it is so there's
some real potential in that because it
isn't something you do just naturally
there's sort of no one product no one
team or something that's going to
produce the the winning capability in
there that's got to be an evolution so
every one of these Nick's should be free
to start learning how it doing it itself
and this is the place within the
Alliance to start assessing analyzing
it's just like no one outfit in LA I is
in competing going to design and tone
the best lean system a lot of evolution
going on then how you get the best case
studies and the assessment of it that
you integrate in here so everybody can
watch you make a better environment for
all of the members to evolve in and so
excuse me so this is a brief e about the
improvement community but then there was
a strategy about how you how you can
really get maximum leverage out of that
in this bootstrapping sense so that's
sort of saying if you're bootstrap
Alliance is careful that early on it it
looks at what we call the bootstrapping
index for a NIC that is how much are the
capabilities that that Nick is trying to
prove among its members are capabilities
that brought back into the Alliance will
help be something you can distribute in
every Nick would need see and so we just
find some real value in that so so you
know like la I over here it's not its
dominant pursuit but it's going to have
good ideas to share etcetera but there
are some communities that we've been
knocking on the door of that I think
there's a series of examples we have
next
so these candidates would have a
bootstrapping so the association of
Computing Machinery has special interest
groups in computer human interaction in
group where in the web is hyper media
stuff so talking those which each is an
improvement community talking those into
becoming Nick's so we've already been
knocking on their doors and say it's
something where they should get funding
for them to start turning into Nick's so
that they accelerate what they're doing
and bring their own capabilities in an
advanced way in for every Nick and a lot
of things about organization and in
coordination etcetera that they don't
posture very well but good solid Nick's
like Ellie I can become when being able
to contribute a lot about how you can
better run and operate those but they'll
these guys will produce much you know
complete very lot of dialogue and
studies and so they're they're
professional societies on strategic
business intelligence on intellectual
capital
on scenario development which is a very
important thing so their whole pursuit
is how do you do better scenario
development so bringing that into every
neck would be very important for going
into the future it's clear that security
is important one inside of every
organization and workflow electronic
commerce etc so and there's no big
problem in going out and finding
improvement community domains that if
you could recruit them to become Nicks
as part of this alliance that their
activity would be very stimulating to
every Nick in value so this is the this
is the that's sort of bootstrapping
strategy and they're like that of how to
do that and so this sort of finishes the
picture about the the bootstrapping and
there are a few other things to talk
about us saying we have quite a few
different organizations that we've been
involved with talking some of them are
getting quite active and some of them
are fairly passive which is the way any
consortium sure starts in that like this
but anyway and internationally the
Japanese chapter formed in there that
were in process of forming explicitly a
u.s. chapter and the current bootstrap
Alliance will be called the
International to try to help facilitate
every nation because every every nation
has a distinctive culture in which the
way in there that that you do the best
at collective knowledge work would need
to evolve and adapt to the culture and
you know the cultures are going to have
to shift and adapt to make that work but
anyway and then at the same time you you
have to have international collaboration
cooperation so you have to have
underlying standards that are the same
and there's a lot you can learn from
each other so it'll be interesting to
see how the Japanese go after that but
one of the early Nick's that they're
really pursuing is trying to get
end-user organizations into this
business of how how did they start
pushing proactively which is a very
important thing anyway and so this
national improvement infrastructure it's
something that would be important you
could have a whole DoD improvement
infrastructure if one wanted to or an
aerospace improvement infrastructure
that could go deeper and broader then
then you guys go and in the DoD you look
at the planning that starts at the
strategic level with the scenarios and
plans then drops down into tactical or
actual emergency situations and you
realize that there's a lot of
concurrency issue about developing that
knowledge and that in a lot of ways to
make that organization a lot more
effective if they try to do it all by
themselves they're going to miss out on
what the rest of the world and the
commercial look contributions and all
the other organizations are doing to
learn how to make organizational
effectiveness a lot higher so it's
because the Defense Department to
participate in this so anyway the the
sort of innocent assumption I have is
and I've been innocent all these years
and that I say well look there's
something where there's a real argument
that's been evolving for years and his
own and has withstood a lot of different
sort of chopping attacks to say oh you
don't you ignore the marketplace and
things like that anyway there's
something there that I think needs
attention and one of the best things
that happen is for us to get actual
dialogue with people like you in there
so it would take some specific
commitment in LA I to sort of pull out
some people and resources to actually
participate in the alliance with the
other emerging ones and even be better
also be well if they could go knock on
other doors that
to say oh this is a bigger scale thing
you'll have to excuse my sniffling and
my hacking I came down with a mixture of
flu and pneumonia month ago on boy I not
recovered yet that's amazing
so anyway this is what I I'd sort of
like to leave you with is the I just
wanted my I got a set of pet peeves and
one of them is that the Apple Macintosh
steadfastly only has one button on the
mouse and we had three and somebody says
how did you pick three
well it's only because for the current
status microswitches the stuff three are
all we could get on from house and how
you can work your hands better and
connect better it's something we just
need to break away from anyway that's a
substance of another whole lecture okay
so there's a whole open source pursuit
and I just have to close rapidly because
without her on there I'm trying to be
awkward
awkwardly honest about
uncharacteristically honest no whatever
in closing on time but there's this OHS
is something that we're also getting
trying to build communities that want to
participate in its evolution and every
end user community like this should get
involved and that in what you're going
to want to see happen and so that well
he'll open source is a really brand new
way to go after complex software and
high-performance teams are a really
important strategic part of all this
thing and it doesn't mean you go to some
university and say make us make a
high-performance team that can show how
dazzling stuff
it means recruiting and equipping and
training a group of people for real
application
and work inside your organization's
and there's some very clear ways in
which strategically that can be done and
a very clear way in which that would
facilitate evolution and that leads them
to the they sort of say another thing
that's necessary is to have in your tool
system have classes of user interface so
you could have sort of the pedestrian
class or even the handicap class whether
it's handicapped this way or digitally
or whatever but also grades of higher
performance all it can work will the
same knowledge base and then it gives
you the idea about high performance
support teams is another whole thing it
take while to develop that in some
substantial way in your minds but that's
a very important thing and the key
utilization for them is to support
larger conventionally capable
communities organizations or project
teams etc so that's a another whole
strategic thing that if that got started
in introducing those into your world
what would add an element of it's like
those outposts out in the frontier it
would add a very very important element
in a lot of ways to the way in which
you're not only le I could evolve with
your organization's so this multi class
user interface is very important on our
systems have had that in the past there
there are many many things so I think
pretty soon I'm going to come to the end
here's here's a serious estimate was
made that in 30 years the world's
knowledge will double every three months
and say say wow just think
so you assumingly the world's knowledge
about the dynamics all sorts of things
the electronics the many things will
change their role at to your world so
how do your particular knowledge
specialists evolved to keep up with that
what happens in universities are going
to who's going to provide the education
and dr. nation that this really big
changes so anyway
how do you keep here your knowledge of
posit Ori dynamically updated in 73
months or every month or every week or
every day so it becomes a really really
critical thing so it's sort of like a
human's reflexes you know if you're in a
complex environment like say you've got
the ball and you're trying to do open
field running boy you got it you've got
to just pick up everything right away
and integrate it into your your new
plans and changes well more and more of
the world's going to get like that so ok
I did it I'm 42 seconds over
[Applause]
question and answer period we're gonna
have a panel later this morning and I
would encourage you if you have a
question just write on a piece of paper
and leave it on the front table here and
Dan ruse is a fast reader he can process
knowledge quickly and maybe you can
figure out how to incorporate your your
curiosities into the panel I think we
timed our break well I feel like I've
gotten the you know this cartoon I have
which shows this odd kid you know with
kind of eyes that are coming out the
side of his head and he raised his hand
says teacher teacher can I be excused my
mind is full let's take a break we back
at 10:30 and feel free to engage Doug
one on one if you want to pursue
anything further